think about it if you're a guy and
you're married to a girl and she hasn't
had sex with you with six months she's
gained 100 pounds you're barely
attracted to this girl but if you break
it up break it off with her what happens
oh she can take half your oh she
can take the kids and I'll let you see
them and you're like oh just break it
off just leave well why did he cheat and
a lot of times
instead of looking at where the men are
coming from and asking yourself the
question how did I contribute to this
you want to just put it on the men did
you gain a bunch of weight have you been
nagging him 24 7
most men aren't looking to go out and
cheat most men
it is hard to get sex and they're not
looking to do it what are you doing that
drove him to go out and look for
something elsewhere and usually women
have a part to play and they don't want
to admit it